لا تثق قط برجل له لحيه مثل هذه الكلام
للرئيس العراقي السابق صدام حسين عن زعيم
تنظيم القاعده اسامه بن لادن خلال
استجوابه من عميل مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي الامريكي جورج بيرو عقب اعتقاله
قبل 20 عاما
وخلال اول 30 ثانيه من الموعد اكتشف صدام
حسين ان المحقق من اصول لبنانيه استجواب
ماراثوني استمر لسبعه اشهر في غرفه لساعات
كل يوم كشف خلاله صدام حسين انه لا يحب بن
لادن وانه لا يؤمن بايديولوجيه القاعده
فهي تهدف الى اقامه دوله دينيه في جميع
انحاء العالم العربي حسب صدام حسين الذي
لم يكن راغبا في التخلي عن السلطه لاي شخص
عملوا الاف بي اي قال ايضا ان الدعاء صدام
امتلاكه اسلحه دمار شامل كان خدعه تهدف
الى ابعاد جارته وعدوه اللد ود ايران اذ
ساورته مخاوف من غزوها بلاده ان هي عرفت
مدى ضعفه
الرئيس العراقي الراحل اعترف كذلك بانهيار
برنامج اسلحه الدمر الشامل بعد عقوبات
واشنطن اثر غزوه الكويت وانه كان ينوي
اعاده بناء برنامج اسلحه الدمار الشامل
اذا رفعت العقوبات قبل ان تغير هجمات
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر اتجاهات التاريخ
صدام حسين كشف ايضا انه كان يعرف ان جيشه
لن يصمد سوى ايام في حال هجوم اميركا عليه
لكنه توقع حرب تمرد لسنوات عديده بلال
الوجداني العربيه